What do you think?
>> See, I'm not interested. What's the
problem?
>> Why you not interested on me? What do
you think?
>> See, I'm not interested. What's the
problem?
>> Why you not interested on me? And I'm
just appalled. I am genuinely appalled
and disappointed. Is this the future
woman that our children, sons are going
to marry? Is this the future husbands
that we're going to give our daughters
to? It's disgusting. And it's all about
aesthetics. Subhan Allah. You are there
sing over her. Why? Because of her
looks. Come on, man.
guys. Before the video starts, brothers
and sisters, one Umar is working in
Pakistan with the floods that's hit the
country. 1,700 people have lost their
life. Millions of people have lost their
homes and been displaced. So the videos
that you can see here, the pictures that
you can see guys is demonstrating what
one is doing on the ground. We know Gaza
is important and we know what's going on
there. But brothers and sisters, we
cannot enable and turn a blind eye to
the suffering of Muslims in different
countries. Be it Pakistan, be it Turkey,
the earthquakes, wherever it may be,
Afghanistan, so many other places need
our help. And I know all of us have
given as much as we can to Gaza. But
brothers and sisters, wahi, just imagine
your home wrecked. Thousands of people
have died. Your family members have
passed away. You have nowhere to live.
Brothers and sisters, they need our help
as much as Gaza does. So I urge you
guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. Donate whatever amount, even if
it's one pound. The prophet peace be
upon him said, "The best form of saddak
is to give water." Brothers and sisters,
let's give them food and shelter and
water to drink so they can overcome this
tragedy. Inshallah, I urge you guys to
go to the link and donate now. Enjoy the
video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
we're in the year 2025 and
things are getting cringier and cringier
and more embarrassing and sadly we are
losing our modesty and hire as we go
along. This is a video that I came
across and I was in double mind.
And I'll be honest with you, I'm going
to be I'm going to have double standards
in this matter. I believe I have some
evidence from the Quran and the Sunnah.
I'm going to be blurring the sister's
face and not the brothers. Why? We're
going to watch the reaction in for
firstly I believe she's extremely caked
herself up. Number one, anyone that
usually when a woman's extremely caked
up, I usually blur their face. Other
than that, I don't cuz I don't believe
the face is. But in this instance, I
believe this video would and I don't
intend to cause damage to anyone. And I
think their video in itself causes
damage. They shouldn't blame me. But I
just want to save her from, you know,
brothers not wanting to marry her, etc.
Number two, when it comes to the man,
sadly, he doesn't need to have that
issue even though he's as blamew worthy
as he is. And I'm going to um give my
two pence uh two cents about him. But
I'm going to blur her face and not his
because to him, this doesn't really
tarnish his image to that level as it
was. We with her. Let's watch the video
and you guys can understand. Okay, what
am I talking about here? Inshallah. Here
is two individuals on a live Tik Tok and
this is what what how it transpired.
Let's watch for ourself.
>> But I'm falling in love with you.
>> Well, this is not my problem.
>> Of course, you can do dua for me. I'm
not I'm ugly in your your eyes.
>> Okay, just let me just stop you there.
Let's dissect this piece by piece in
firstly. Okay. Um number one, why are
you guys on that platform? If I'm not
mistaken, this is a Tik Tok competition
thing where you make money. Now, subhan
Allah, from what I can see, there are
actually married men and married women
who are on these platforms. Number one,
this is free mixing. Like, this is free
mixing. Even though they are not in the
same building together, this is the
definition of free mixing. On what
purpose, on what grounds are you guys
coming together to casually chitchat,
laugh from both angles? Number one, this
brother. Yes. Why are you speaking to
other women? I don't give married or
not. It's both not permissible. You're
casually freem mixing. Number two with
her as well. Yes. Both sides should have
ha. Why are you speaking to non men? Why
are you speaking to non mahim woman?
Yes. And not only that, sister, you have
caked yourself up. Yes. And you are
there softening your voice. Like Allah
says in the Quran, do not soften your
voice for there will be a people who
have a disease in their heart. Okay. So
number one, from the get- go, you are
there. And this is on dishonorable way.
You're trying to make money by going
there. Wa is shameful. I'm so sorry. You
can speak. I don't want to give a
You go to scholars and if they no
scholar will come and say you can make
money by speaking to the opposite
gender. It's free mix. It's haram. It is
haram. People that complain about oh you
know this that etc on your ads whatever
those makes your income haram. This can
also let's carry on. So number one what
is the intention of the conversation? It
is not for the sake of Allah. It's not
pretending to help the dean. What is it?
It's a casual chitchat and laughing and
joking un absolutely unnecessary. I hope
you guys enjoyed the video guys. But
before that, please download the Salah
Pro app. Brothers and sisters, we are a
charity. All of our services on the app
is for free. Free kibla finder, no ads,
free salah reminders, encourages to
pray, tells you salah times. You can
book a salah instructor, a Quran
instructor. You can order a guided
prayer map for absolutely free if you
want to learn how to pray salah. Videos
on how to pray salah, salah hubs, and
many, many more. Brothers and sisters,
we are not an app that shares your
information with third parties. All of
our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video.
>> This is not about ugly. Please.
>> Yeah, but why you don't even inter why
you not interested on me?
>> It's not about looks.
I mean, one thing I need to say to the
brothers, wah Muslims,
you can have some halal game. You can
have some halal game genuinely. And I
think this is what we're lacking as men.
A lot of men have some halal game. Have
some integrity, bro. The guy, the girl
is basically telling you in a nutshell
and you are there. I don't mean this.
Look, I'm genuinely not trying to be
disrespectful to any side. I'm trying to
be objective to the best of my ability.
Yes, she's basically saying, let me
just,
>> this is not about ugly, please.
>> She's she's basically saying, "Oh, why
are you not interested in me?" Bro,
that's so desperate. And a woman doesn't
like that. You're desperate. If there's
anything that woman gives a woman an ick
is desperation. Number one, you should
not be talking to each other. Number
two, have some halal game. There should
be some halal game. Have some integrity.
Do you get it? Don't be so in the face
like you know be interested women don't
like that I'm giving you a brotherly
advice yes with all Jewish I'm not
saying I'm some you know no genuinely I
come from a jahilia I have some
experience in Islam as well you know
I've come to know sisters for marriage
in a halal way there should be some game
bro there should be some you know you
have some you know selfrespect you know
the way you carry yourself and she's
yeah and and this is this is called a
sing and let's be honest I don't I'm not
trying to blame you my brother genuinely
comes across simp let's carry on
>> uh If about money,
>> if I go after look and money, I'm never
going to be single. Uh today,
>> I'll be honest with you, sister. If you
carry on the way you carry on, you um
you'll be single for a long time. If you
are there casually speaking to men, yes,
vice versa. And and even yourself, Aki.
Yes. With all due respect, yeah, you're
there casually. I'll be honest with you.
Um if you came to ask for my daughter's
hand, brother, you're getting rejected,
bro. Get the hell out of my house, man.
You're just casually speaking to woman
on live. If this was done in private,
you can say, you know what? Even then
it's it's it's wrong. But publicly, you
know, out there, you know, for both, you
know, I'll be honest with you. And even
her, even her, if I had a son, he come
and say to me, I'm marrying this one and
I found this. I said, "Hell no, you are
not marrying this woman." Yes. Casually
speaking to a guy trying to is trying to
chirp her, etc. Let's carry on.
>> Okay. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry.
>> No, no, but it's true. Like, let's be
honest, you know. I don't It's not about
>> What do you think who you are? What do
you think? Who you are? You think you
are better than me? You You think you
are better?
>> I didn't say so.
>> Okay, you can see. I mean, this is this
this shows insecurity. And again, this
is something that gives a woman an ack.
The fact that you have insecurity. If
somebody says they're attracted to you,
it's totally fine. Do you get what I'm
trying to say? And it doesn't need to be
attraction. It can be incompatibility. I
when I was looking to get married, get
married, there was times where I've I
want to use the word reject, but I said,
you know, we're not compatible. And
there were times where I was told we're
not in compatible. I totally respect
that. There's been times where I said,
may Allah bless you, sister. I do
respect that you're upfront about it.
May Allah bless and preserve you and
grant you someone that's better about
your business, bro. No. Hey, but please
but you have some integrity, bro. No.
Okay, that's fine. You respect that,
bro. Let me tell you something. At least
in that woman's eyes, you have some
integrity. And there is if there is a
chance for her to pick you is in that
moment when you do this. Look, you
getting angry, bro. You're getting
angry. Yes. Okay. Number one, this is
not right. And one thing I want to
mention which is pertinent and key to
the sister. I want to ask this sister.
Yes. Okay. Because men are known to
approach women in public. So I'm not
going to see it from his angle. Yes.
Which should not be done in this way. By
the way, this is in a man's perspective.
It's wrong. From your perspective,
sister, if you was in the public, if
this man approached you in this way,
would you would you would you entertain
it? Number one, you showed clearly on
the live or in private or in in a in a
public, let's say place, you want to
entertain her because you're not
interested. You don't you don't find him
interesting. No problem. And I can see
and I don't blame her with all due
respect. I'm sorry the way you're
behaving. Number two, at least your
modesty will come in and you will say
no. Or if you're interested, you can go
about the right way, you can speak to my
father, etc. Now, I want to ask a simple
question then.
Why is it that when it's a live, you
entertain it? Because it clearly showed
you're not interested in him. Why are
you carrying on this conversation?
There's another intense in incentive
which is what? Monetary or what? Passing
time. This is free mixing. Yes. This is
what free mixing is by the way guys.
Yeah. Because people people accusing me.
This this is freemixing. Okay. When we
was doing the bitter truth show, we was
in the same building. It was not free
mixing. This they're not in the same
building. It's free mixing cuz it's
unnecessary chit chatter. Nothing to do
with the dean and is go into
conversations of you know you're
interested in me, you're not interested
in me. So you can clearly see and it is
very and again anyone that makes a
living out of this. I don't care if you
are a married or not. This is let me
tell you something. It is haram free
mixing. Your income could be deemed as
haram. I'm not someone that can give
that uh factor. So you can see subhan
allah that from her nature she's
hypergamous and basically she's you know
this this doesn't attract her bro. This
does not attract her at all. But let's
carry on.
>> What do you think?
>> See I'm not interested. What's the
problem?
>> Why you not interested on me? Why you
not interested on me?
>> Oh my gosh man. Oh my god. I didn't
think it would get worse.
Well Muslim men need hal game bro. What
is this? Is this how Muslim men are
moving? Like look, I'm not the
occurrence itself is not permissible.
Yeah. Aki, brothers, brothers, brothers.
Man, brothers, is this how you've become
simps, bro?
Bro, it makes me sick, man.
Bro, have some to yourself, bro. Or like
have some respect, have some game, bro.
When you carry yourself, let that woman
see confidence in you, bro. Let that
woman see that you are a man of
certainty, that you are self-confident.
This brother doesn't have
self-confidence. You don't want me. You
think I'm ugly. You're this. Why are you
saying that? And then not only that,
look, listen to this.
>> What do you think?
>> Say I'm not interested. What's the
problem?
>> Why you not interested on me?
>> Wall. If a woman said to me, I'm not
interested in you. I would never utter,
why are you not interested in me? W I
would say, okay, no problem. I respect
that. May Allah give you someone better.
Bye-bye. Simple as that. Let's carry on.
>> I'm not ugly. I'm Muslim, too. It's not
about ugly.
>> It's about religion. I am Muslim. No,
>> it's not about religion either.
>> Okay, look look it's look bro the woman
is shutting you down from all angles.
It's not even about religion. Okay,
number one like I said before brothers
and sisters in this instance you can see
subhan Allah the prophetam said a woman
is married for four number one lineage
number two beauty number three religion
number four I cannot remember and he
said pick religion now this is one thing
I want to tell brothers and sisters this
sister is wearing a jil babab this
brother he's got a beard whatever you
want to call it and he's he's not
wearing tight clothes etc yeah do not
ever this One lesson I learned in my
marriage seeking process. Do not ever
judge anybody.
I was getting to know sis for marriage.
You were in
the the questions they they would ask
me.
Don't ever fall for this. Look, he has a
beard. He has a Quran, a maswok, a big
maswak, you know, brushes his teeth, his
big teeth with it. Yeah. Let me tell you
something. Yeah. The team's laughing in
the back. Yeah. Let me tell you
something. It means nada zero.
Look at this. Let's just let's just
carry on. Wah. This is appalling.
Appalling. And this the reason why. Let
me tell you something. Yeah, my dear
sister and my brother. Yeah. Wah. Is it
worth going there making a few quids a
pound? Your integrity, you modesty. I'll
be honest with you, this is a massive
put off. I would never let my daughter
marry a man like him. Neither would I
let my son close come close to the
vicinity of her sadly I'm not saying
they are totally I'm not saying that I'm
saying this here if you can just
casually talk yeah
but to me this is a a thing where I
would not to overlook it's a flag red
flag she may in the materialist sense
use for example oh look how many men are
interested in me but let me tell you
something those kind of men are simps
like this guy here because those kind of
men who look at this and think that you
have a value by so many men approaching
Let me tell you something. We as men, we
prefer the less woman that appro less
men that approach our woman or the woman
that we're going to marry, her value
goes up, not vice versa. So a man of a
duny, a s, a coward, a a little weasel
who has no backbone, who's desperate,
who's insecure, might be interested and
say, "Oh, I want to marry her." But a
man of dean, a man of structure,
discipline, somebody who has a backbone,
who has self-respect for himself and is
confident in himself will look at this
and say, "This is not a woman that I
would like to marry or make the mother
for my children." That's the reason I
blurred her face because I believe this
video would harm her unintentionally cuz
her video is public, by the way. Yes.
So, I don't want blame on me. Would harm
her more than this guy. Yes. I'm doing a
double standard.
>> It's about what? I'm not interested.
>> Oh, bro. I'm get you know when she said
I'm not interested, bro. I it's I'm
getting secondhand uh embarrassment.
Yeah. She said bedtime. She's not
interested. Bro, bro, look off.
>> You You need to be interested.
>> Allahbar.
Brother,
you're telling her you need to be
brother. What do you mean you have to be
interested in me? Aki Islamic. She has a
right to say she's not interested in
you. Bro, she's not. She's told you five
times, man. Have some shame. Is this a
joke? Well, I'm standing. Is this par?
I'm assuming the best. Is this a parody,
bro? Is this is this a joke? Is this
someone that you know? Is this your
wife? You guys are just playing games.
>> Of course.
You
>> look how is it end? Him calling her
beautiful and laughing.
And you know what it is? If you look at
it, sister, you're entertaining that
because the more he's talking, you can
just say, "Look, brother, with all your
respect, can you flipping?" Look, if
this was in public, if this was in
public, you would not do this. My dear
sister, this is an from you. Yes.
Usually when I do these videos, you
reach out to me. The brother says, "I'm
assuming you're going to reach out to
me. I need you to reach out to me." I'm
just saying this. Yeah. You put yourself
in these situations. We as Muslims,
Allah says in the Quran, enjoying the
good and the evil. Let there rise
amongst you. And I'm not trying to be
that pious guy who does that. But wall,
it hurts me to see that sisters have
come to this level where this and I'm
not trying to say she's like, she's
somebody's sister. I don't mean any
disrespect. Well, lie. But I'm upset the
way you're behaving and carrying
yourself and you as a man. The same goes
for you, bro. The same goes for you. How
are you so casually talking to her, bro?
It's haram. This is free mixing, bro.
A Allah is strange, man. Have some hay.
Where's the modesty gone, bro? And
people come and have a go at me. You are
your expo. Shut the hell up, man. Please
just shut the hell up. They have no hay
and shame just talking like this
casually. And I'm the ones who's going
to have I'm going to be shy. Can you
imagine? No. You be the one that sh you
hold on. No. No.
Because the prophetam said you either
enjoying good and forbid evil or Allah
will send down a calamity that even if
you prostrate you'll be rejected.
This dean is about advising one another.
If you see something in me, you ran me.
You tell me. Yes. There's a way we
conduct ourself.
And I'm just appalled. I am genuinely
appalled and disappointed. Is this the
future woman that our children, sons are
going to marry? Is this the future
husbands that we're going to give our
daughters to? It's disgusting.
And it's all about aesthetics.
Subhan Allah. You are there sing over
her. Why? Because of her looks. Yes.
Because of her looks. You want to make
this with all your respect. Yes. She's
clearly told she's not interested in
you. You're still sing. Come on, man.
That's all I have to say, brothers and
sisters. Wai. All I want to And I
blurred her face, covered her face
because as a woman, like we know from
the Quran and Sunnah, the seven major
sins, one of them is to um accuse a
chase woman of adultery. Alhamdulillah,
we're not doing anything close to that.
We know she's an honorable woman. We're
not saying nothing. I'm just saying that
modesty higher element both sides. But I
know this will cause her more harm cuz
that not that to to a man it's not that
deep for us. We have to be just that's
why you see there's sometimes double
standards which is necessity in this
matter. Yep. Because in the Quran in
hadith, it talks about the chastity of a
woman. That's more her it will cause
more harm for her than the man. It's the
reality. That's it brothers and sisters.
That's all I want to say in Till next
time.
Inshallah. Anything that I said wrong is
for myself and anything good is from
Allah.
Brothers and sisters, when you're
seeking marriage, please brothers and
sisters
look for something more than just hijab
and this that etc. and looks.